The joe rogan experience. I've been
doing, uh, rose and my trainer. Oh yeah.
I do that too. That he wrote down
a thousand meter row and I'm like,
what's a good time? So we looked
up the top times. I'm like,
I think I'm top 300 in the
world right now. A bit, you
know, I got to do some work.
It was a big guy. There's big difference
between top 300 in the top hundred. Yeah,
but dude, you're top 300 in the world
with a row. With a rail. Yeah, look it up.
That's pretty fucking sweet.
It's all right. I mean,
it's a row machine on the top 85
million. I mean, no, you're the hold up.
You're the, hold on, hold on. Let's just,
I would that, that was the humble brag,
but let's just be serious there.
You're the,
you're the hardest kicker ever on
that Goddamn UFC machine. Well,
I call it the Francis Machine. Well, I,
there's a video of me doing 152 right?
Right now.
You only see the one that me kicking it
and with my jeans on and that what got
to one 35 stretchy jeans. Yeah. Then
a barbell jeans, basically pds. PDS,
like sweatpants, man. So dude burned me,
burned me from the audience, and he goes,
hey man, how long did it take you
to paint on those genes? And I went,
oh my goodness sir.
He just scorched me.
Theo van did me dirty, brought weird
clown on each other, clarify each other.
I said, you look like an extra
from the waterboy setting. He goes,
he goes, don't fuck. I've probably cause
I think he goes, Bro, you look like you.
You look like you work at Nordstrom's
rack and you're a mechanic. I was like,
fuck. He talking about, he's so thing,
but that fucking pants man. These
pants or the shit, these are different.
These right now I have on there similar,
they're called Mott and bow is a no,
those are good company. Yeah.
Those are like legit jeans.
They'd like more feel like
jeans where the barbell jeans,
they look like jeans to touch them
and I go, hey, what's going on here?
Like sweat sweatpants on son.
That's at a good company to Jacob,
but just so bind you up a little bit more
if you were trying to kick somebody's
a little bit more. So what did you do?
The record setting. Kid barbell jeans.
This is the all day I did the record on.
This is the record one.
I see that dos Anjos rump. Let's
see, you saw my, he'll run in men.
My ass is way bigger. A lot of people
have been complimented me on it.
Nothing wrong with it. I don't like that
fat belly though. I'm so fat right now.
You are not fat for me.
One 52
and what's the hardest? No, I'm
definitely fatter than I usually am.
I been cheating on my died way too much.